foreign
Castle hate school today we are talking
to vigorous Steve I'm still hella more
Carly even though I didn't say that at
the outset okay uh I'm just excited for
you guys to see this episode we just
recorded vigorous Steve is one of my
favorite people on the internet I think
he's a great guy but more specifically
his content on YouTube
I would consider the number one source
of good ped information
on the internet
let that sink in
he's somebody who I really hope I'll
talk to again in the very near future
and we discuss that in the podcast he's
hopefully coming to La soon
but for now I'm going to let you enjoy
the episode and make sure you go
subscribe to his channel Vigor Steve
after you watch this
but that if you come out it would be
really cool to go to Golds with you
would be really cool to go go to zoo you
know I'm sure we'll meet up at one of
those places
um yeah and I've been uh I've been
lifting with Michael Hearn at zoo
culture I saw that yeah
um really good dude
like he's just I feel like every time I
train with him
I pick up something new and you kind of
like I think that's something that he
isn't given enough credit for is like he
is a master of like bodybuilding he's
been in the game for such a long time
yeah he always gets [ __ ] for um you know
the the allegedly lying about his
steroid use but the guy's in his 50s he
just had a kid and he looks better than
most of us so whatever he is doing yeah
like he's and not telling us about it
yeah it's obviously working you know
yeah you got to give him some credit I'm
taking notes and even just on a training
level like first of all I I think he's
his temperament and his generosity with
people that I've seen like he's a guy's
guy and he is also very like quick to
compliment other people which I think is
always this like to me that's like just
a sign of a healthy individual you know
somebody who's not like
[ __ ] on other people to make
themselves feel good but and exactly
what I did yeah well you know we're in
an industry for such a long time you
should be complimentary and then you
know Inspire others yeah because you
know in this industry there's a lot of
negativity especially online yeah when
we all meet each other in real life it
should be fun and interesting yeah you
know a lot of positivity going on yeah
because I feel that the online stuff is
just kind of ruining it a little bit you
know yeah and it's even something where
I started out this podcast thinking I do
like Natty or not more often but I
realized I'm just it doesn't interest me
that much because ultimately you can't
unless you put that you know you open up
that person's memories and and could
climb inside there and see whether or
not they've done that it's sort of this
moot point it's just like a gossip
debate basically and exactly you know
and it's ultimately irrelevant to like
you know my personal experience my
favorite physiques have either come from
you know being Natty and just being
really strict in my diet or running like
150 tests and some master on you know
and just my training and you know
whatever my diet at that time were
better so I always feel like it's the
easiest thing to go to for people who
are maybe not totally happy with their
own physiques and so I've started doing
more joking ones like I'll look at like
Bruce Wayne you know and be like is he
Natty or not Batman you know like in the
comics um or I did one on Christmas
would take all the angles possible right
yeah that's that's uh and so I think
that's that's actually
all right I call it a super soldier
serum s you know for a reason yeah I
know it's steroids but they can't say it
in the Marvel Comics yeah so we all know
it's uh right yeah you're making me
think of the irony of like the rock you
know being in all these or whoever is in
the you know every you know he's just
the prime example but everybody in the
movies uh we're watching movies about
guys doing steroids and being America's
hero
but we can't let the actors admit that
they're doing steroids
yeah but during the Limelight they got
sponsorship deals you know I mean you
saw what happened with um the guy that
did the Tour de France uh yeah
yeah right Lance Armstrong and then at
one point you know the the the Scandal
started coming out yeah and and all his
sponsors dropped him but also sued him
wow I didn't know that you know for the
for them for the money back so you know
like I always thought like if you're in
the fitness industry like did we start
the podcast yeah yeah yes we are yeah
okay we're already rolling
we did a soft starts
right so we're in the fitness industry
right and and I try to educate about
steroid use and and how to do that
safely so I can be open and transparent
about my personal use and maybe other
people can learn from that right and and
maybe you're open about your schedules
because you just want to keep it real
with everybody right you don't want to
say that the haters will say that you're
a fake man exactly we don't want that
right but if you're the rock or you're a
Chris Hemsworth preparing for Thor
um or or any other movie role
it's kids movie you know yeah you can't
say I took stairs because maybe there's
some 14 year old kids out there saying I
want to look like Thor so I gotta take
primavola or I want to look like
Wolverine so I kind of take Winstrol
yeah I want to look like the rock so I
gotta take an Angelo as an example yeah
and it's you know at one point we'll all
get exposed to it anyway
when we get a little bit older and wiser
but it might be a little bit too early
for some kids or or general population
who just doesn't want to hear and have
such a stigma about steroid use I mean
while they're drinking booze while
they're watching you know American
football and then yeah they're watching
the game but they're not playing the
game yeah so they're they're they're not
a part of the the culture so for them
just let them be and they can do what
they want and and talk whatever and then
for us we have our little niche clicky
um group of people where we're just you
know you're in the gym you're like hey
what's up what are you taking
the GH you know I took a little bit of
Aromas into control of estrogen yeah
right and then we're clear about I just
think that you know people that are so
super popular just it's just better to
keep your mouth shut yeah and and you
bring up a good point that it's not just
about the self-preservation aspect of it
which I also respect like because look I
I just saw a video of Ronnie Coleman on
Jay Leno in the 90s or early 2000s and
you asking you know so you take anything
anyways and he's like nope totally
natural again I've actually kind of have
the same voice almost you know yeah
totally natural
um but it's just the position that
you're in and you've made that choice
and I feel
um
I I feel like this freedom to do this
it's it's uh it's something that I'm
grateful for that I am able to speak
openly without major there probably are
some consequences you know uh given that
I that I pursue you know commercial
acting work in Hollywood there's
probably some element to this at some
point but I've just made that personal
calculation for myself that I I I want
to ascend whatever ranks you know by
being transparent or carrying the weight
of that transparency because I I think
like there's there's a huge demand for
keeping it real nowadays you know Joe
Rogan is keeping it real and you're
keeping it real and there's so many guys
in in with podcasts in the public space
on YouTube and Spotify that keep it real
and there's a huge demand for that as
well because people see the actors just
something I'm not fake but they're
portraying something else right it's
it's bigger than life it's a movie role
we know that it's something else in the
real world but if you do a podcast you
try to entertain people and and share
some ideas then being open about it
that's okay I just think that some guys
that used to say that they were natural
now have to keep up appearances yeah
because they've been saying it so long
that they can't go back so yeah yeah in
the 90s I said it was natural in 2000s I
said it was natural now it's 2020. I've
been on steroids all along so you're
going back and your words
no I I yeah and it sounds like you
empathize with this as well because I do
um you know where I go uh it's a
difficult thing because you you built
this life around uh you know a certain
projection of your image at a time when
there was no other option and it does
just look really bad it's like yeah some
people you just kind of die with that
secret and that's like so I and I guess
I used to maybe judge that more harshly
but then I think back to like you know
um I was gonna bring this up with you
because I you know I'm interested in
your like anabolic origin story in
addition to your bodybuilding origin
story which of course are you know gonna
be two different things but for me you
know I was lifting from like probably
like 14 to 18 and and you know I was
just buying Cell Tech and creatine
thinking like well riding home
Interstate Celtic right and then in the
early internet I got on this website
called steroid encyclopedia and I
remember it was always spelled in the in
the British way yeah yeah and so I paid
the 20 bucks a month or whatever to have
access you know to these I remember some
of the usernames are like Doc sustin you
know and uh I I would said Western Union
or MoneyGram transfers and I were trying
to do it online they're like you can't
send it online to this location so I'd
have to like like go into the thing call
it in or go into like a Western Union
like deal with a person or sometimes
just give your passport details yeah and
wait till yeah and then the person you
spelled my name wrong you we have to go
in again right and so nowadays we use
Bitcoin or exactly and people are still
frustrated with that process so they're
always going like you know I'm happy to
show people how that I obtain this but
it's just like most people uh perceive
it as being very cumbersome they try to
do it and they're like you know the
three
DDOS
safeguards before this dark web thing or
no can you just do it for me it's like
well I don't want to do that like it's
it's time consuming it's not amazon.com
right yeah so if you want to do it you
know if you want to go the direction you
got to learn how to do it all yourself
you know yeah the funny thing is about
this this whole steroid thing and
getting the information like
before on YouTube it was also a taboo to
talk about it and many of them yeah
YouTube channels that talked about
steroids that got shut down oh I didn't
know that because I found Greg you said
actually from him talking about his Pro
bodybuilding cycle and I don't think I'd
I think he was the first pro that I'd
seen talk about a biting building cycle
and it all checked out you know I was
like okay that makes sense based on what
I'd read but I was going to say earlier
going on these bodybuilding forms trying
to figure out my first cycle I took Deca
d-ball and test and you know even though
it was like two 250 tests 300 Deca 25
milligrams I mean I gained like 30
pounds in a month and everybody knew you
know I was like oh it's gonna be subtle
and it's like I just you know and I have
good like I was I was a good responder
to it as well and was working my ass off
but it's like like if if you if I
thought I was for like one single person
you know uh with all the water retention
and just strength increases and whatever
you know I look like a different human
in a few weeks
um
everybody everybody knows nobody's gonna
know everybody knows
um you know and so that's why I actually
you know we'll get to this later but I
always forward your video on
the if you look up vigorous Steve
beginner approved beginner ped uh
compounds for people to use I would
consider it the best video on the
internet to introduce somebody in a safe
way to what you should do as a beginner
because that's probably the most common
question I see myself as a sort of a
conduit you know to people like you or
Leo or more plates more dates where it's
like I'm not going to get these super
technical questions but I get a lot of
people saying
um I want to start what's that first
step and you know you just provided a
great groundwork that like I wish I had
you back in the day right we did we had
a bunch of bodybuilding forms you know
with like exactly we start off with 500
tests you know and 500 Primo or or even
like equipoise deck whatever everybody
was recommending too much for their
first cycle and that was like you saw it
as the norm and then you're jumping in
and you're getting all this side effects
when it does doesn't have to be that way
so maybe you can talk about that yeah
and most of that you know in the steroid
forms again it was way too much and we
didn't know what people looked like so
you would take advice from people you
know maybe they didn't even take
steroids themselves that's true
absolutely yeah you know they maybe had
an avatar deal with the side effects
yeah so that's why I started my YouTube
channel because after you know 20 years
in the sports and about half the time on
steroids I figured you know what I think
I have some information to transfer I
have a YouTube channel about it and and
try to make other you know prevent other
people from making the same mistakes so
I thanks so much for recommending that
that first cycle video I Remember You
yeah for over a year now yeah now you
specifically mentioned if you want to
use insulin on your first cycle only
under guided yeah yeah yeah cause I got
a lot I got so much [ __ ] for that
segment but I you know from my
experience like if you're a hardcore
bodybuilder or you're really passionate
about the sport in your diet at some
point and you're trading at some point
and you're living the lifestyle you have
all this health supplementation and
you're doing your blood work and you
know how the glucometer Works to check
your blood glucose levels then I think
it's better to incorporate a little bit
of long-acting insulin yeah which is
very little risk for you to go
hypoglycemic that's low blood sugar
levels and then minimize the amount of
steroids that you take yeah because it's
ultimately higher dosages of steroids
that is going to make you unhealthy not
the insulin yes and of course I know
everybody in the comment section is
going to say insulin is going to kill
you it's going to be this and that and
you can die with one mistake
but there's hundreds of people out there
or millions of people out there who have
diabetes who use insulin every day just
to stay alive actually insulin is the
most life-saving medication out there
yeah you just have to use it with
caution yeah so I always tell people if
you want to go on your first cycle okay
you experiment One Drug at a time but it
might be better to incorporate insulin a
low dose very low dose in a single unit
dose over the course of a day from the
start because now you're more anabolic
with less steroids yeah and you see your
recommendations or bang for your body
yeah and I actually want and you have a
whole guide on this that I actually
wanted I it's on my you know to buy list
of things and I'll send it to you oh
okay no thank you because it is I do
like you know and I've thought about you
know maybe writing my own books of just
like hey here's like what I know but
framing it is at it it's like ma what I
know and what I you know can pass on but
you have an advanced pharmacological
understanding you know not only from the
theoretical perspective but you've done
like I assume hundreds if not thousands
of clients and and overseen people do
this so it's like those are the person
people you want to trust because I still
there is so much bro science still on
the internet and you get people kind of
like passing on a facsimile of well okay
anavar that's a cutting Drive they sound
very authoritative you know like this is
what people you're typically gonna you
be used for cutting if you're trying to
lean up and it's like you just said a
hundred words and just didn't say
anything about what the actual chemical
properties or physiological effects of
anavar is you know and so maybe people
don't have the patience for you speaking
with Precision about everything but I
would if you're listening to this and
want if you prioritize you know precise
language because I do think there's like
an ethical obligation all this stuff to
like communicate exactly what this is
what it does what are the side effects
because you know there are uh you know
as you point out insulin is safe but uh
you know if they're safe for them think
but there are dangers of of other you
know androgenic compounds but I was one
of those people who thought that insulin
was going to kill you you know but
you're yeah no well most people and I I
thought the same thing and then you
started reading about it that's why I
wrote an ebook about it about 130 pages
and the first 75 Pages it's just biology
yeah basic human biology so you know
exactly what's going to happen yeah
right why is insulin important how do
you maintain insulin sensitivity how how
much insulin does the body produce even
in a fasted state right that's why we
call it basal insulin your body is
always producing insulin unless you have
diabetes with type 1 diabetes what's
type two what's this magical type 3
diabetes that is now being discussed is
basically diabetes of the brain so right
there's a lot of discussion in that
ebook and then by the end of it you
should have a firm grasp of how to use
it safely yeah and then you see the
dosages like oh 10 units 15 units so
it's so exciting yeah you know and would
you say people can get people get great
results from that yeah I was going to
ask like
you've probably overseen many people
because I think the like the mentality
that I come across a lot somebody was
just asking me like they're doing test
and Primo and they always have this
question of like what's Primo supposed
to do I'm just always like build muscle
like you know like I don't know you know
but that's my basic response maybe you
have a better response but like I I was
actually listening to uh I know you know
Steve Barnett I think is his name uh
with the anabolic bodybuilding Channel
he has a great Channel and he has made
the point on there it's like look all
these things that you're doing you're
just trying to build muscle Tran isn't
per se going to build more muscle or if
there is a comparison it's not much more
than like nandra loan or whatever it
just has different side effect profiles
or different androgenicity right so
maybe you're getting stronger because of
this you know signaling right
um but ultimately if you're trying to
build muscle they all kind of lead
toward the same you know down the same
uh Road toward the same goal but you're
just going which side effects do I want
to juggle right so so you have to kind
of differentiate between
are you a hardcore bodybuilder that's
going to compete or are you a
recreational drug user right not
recreational drugs as an ndma or weed or
whatever but you're using uh steroids
and growth them on that kind of stuff
recreationally to improve your physique
improve your quality of life and then
look a little bit buffer so you have to
differentiate between those two if
you're a competitive bodybuilder then
yes you need to train in all the harsh
stuff to win
but if you're just using a little bit of
PEDs to improve your quality of life use
the drugs
that your body agrees with so if you
your body agrees with Trend a low dose
Trend by all means use it but if you
can't you know can't just train because
you get too angry or night sweats or
whatever your sweat smells like ammonia
and all the horrible side effects that
most people get don't tremolo you'll
test them Primo or you just use tests or
maybe testing so most guys will have to
go through some sort of experimentation
process and then from the the 500 drugs
that we can choose you maybe have a
short list of five and those you use
yeah and then you leave the
experimentation up to guys like me or or
Paul anyway we try new protocols we
document everything we try to figure out
a higher truth and then once our you
know protocol is done we'll we'll
document that on YouTube and make a
video about it and then you guys can
learn so this is something for me yeah
maybe not but it was fun a fun video to
watch yeah and that's true because for
most guys
you know for most guys they will do well
with tests Primo and of our GH and then
at a higher level insulin I think that's
all you need yeah you know and then the
rest are ancillaries to keep yourself
healthy guys how do I do it stay focused
the entire hour of talking to a brain
Genius Like vigorous Steve well I'll let
you in on a little secret it's happy
hippo Kratom where do I get it from
happy hippo herbals.com and I use promo
code thick boy on the rare occasion that
I want to pay money for something that I
get free but when I do pay money for it
I get 20 off but it really helps them in
situations like this where I'm talking
with somebody who's so smart that I have
to use all of my brain capacity just to
keep up with them so if you're around
smart people too and whether it's
chemistry anabolics engineering
mathematics or even just internet gossip
you'll want to take Kratom to keep up
you might have noticed during the
episode Steve can't keep his eyes off my
shirt no he's not staring at my pecs
it's the Oak and stone clothing
now off camera I told him hey look
if you want one of these shirts for
yourself go to oaklandstoneclothing.com
use promo code hello for 10 off and you
could be looking just like me do they
deliver to Thailand honestly I'm not
sure
but he can order it to me and then I'll
send it to him for your charge maybe you
want to take advantage of that situation
too go to oaklandstoneclothing.com use
promo code hella and guess what
everyone around you is gonna say oh he's
sexy right right because as you
differentiate it's like most these
people and you know it is funny how
trend has become this meme in the
fitness industry
um like trenches so but because it's
like a funny joke you know that people
make memes of you know when the trend
kicks in or like that you just Trends
just like almost like the funniest word
to use right
um correct but it has created this
Allure where I get so many questions
about like people aren't asking me about
equipoise or or Deca or anything like
that it's always like so like how much
Trend should I take I'm like this is
your first cycle like and you barely
lift weights or whatever you know I'm
sure you get this a lot too where it's
just like you've your mind has been
hacked into thinking this is the first
step that you take to getting jacked and
it's just not true at all um now I was
gonna it's been romanticized yeah just
like sport sports cards everybody wants
a Ferrari yeah but there's hundreds of
sports cars to choose from I mean I need
that Ferrari right you know and it's the
same with steroids there's there's
multiple steroids you can take but
everybody wants Trend the good thing
about trend is is that you can do
everything wrong and still get results
yeah so that's why the beginners like it
because they might not be in tune with
their body they might not train hard and
diet correctly and take the right
supplement but they take a little bit of
train and they will still get great
results yeah as long as they can you
know manage their brain and it's usually
the guys that are already a little bit
volatile huh let me go on Trend and then
they're more of all the time yeah right
and then that gives the rest of the
industry a bad name but to be fair I
couldn't handle my Trend either I can't
even handle 100 milligrams a week I'll
just go crazy so I haven't touched it in
eight years well yeah I'm still able to
build a decent physique without it yes
no your physique is great and you've
you've uh you know yeah we'll get into
it in a sec I wanted to ask about like
or comment on you doing the uh fasting
mimicking diet and losing a lot of
muscle then putting it right back on but
before that was going to say
the Roid Rage thing because we kind of
trend is almost like synonymous when you
think of like people who are actually
Road raging I've taken trend
the most I've taken is 100 milligrams
per day per 10 days the real thing I
noticed was
super horny and also my workouts
suffered like your cardiovascular
capacity it's the first time I'm like oh
I'm getting it yeah yeah I'm doing six
sets of biceps and I just want to quit
you know
um it's not comfortable you know but I
just had like a bunch of stuff on hand
and I'm like oh I'm gonna shoot a music
video in a couple weeks like if I just
take 100 milligrams of wind straw or
sorry 200 milligrams of one straw a day
100 milligrams trying a day 100
milligrams yeah
so the funny thing is like turn below
and it it's a progesterone compound so
it can activate the progesterone
receptor a little bit that's why some
guys get thicker skin on trembolone yeah
it's mostly upset with dandrillon but
with germ blowing happens also and then
there's some there's a little bit of
evidence that wind stroke can inhibits I
remember reading that back in the day
that you would pair those two like uh
you know like Deca and WinStar go well
together remember that was a cycle I
recommended to somebody right so you so
you take trainer winter they go well
together but because you're sending
weird signals to the progesterone
receptor a lot of people lose out on
stamina so yeah
blood actually makes it worse because
there's one of the mechanism in there
which helps with
oxygen turnover yeah so if you combine
both both your stamina is absolutely
horrible yeah and then you're trying to
dye it at the same time you literally do
a set and then even before you reach
failure already gasping for air yeah
it's it's it's a disgusting combination
you look in the mirror it's all worth it
yeah
and then the weird thing is like you
you're very horny right yeah you want to
have sex but then halfway through your
session you're drenched in sweat yeah
you're already like man I don't know if
I can finish because your heart right
yeah everything is super pumped yeah
that's something you should almost lead
when you're like talking about trainer
guys to ask about it I'm like you know
and maybe not at a smart it's a small
I've taken like 150 a week and I know
they're just like oh it's kicking in
because I'm getting night sweats and I'm
waking up and I just kind of feel that
like like uh andrenergic signaling of
you're waking up at four and it's like
you're just wired you know
um and there's a lot of sweating going
on but yes at the higher doses like that
this was a clicking moment for me where
I go oh this is not worth it you know
like whatever effect I'm getting from
this
I'm somebody who has like I I try to
keep my cardio up I can a lot of people
are shocked I'm like oh yeah I'll run
six miles and they're like huh like I
was talking to Bradley Martin the other
day he's like no you don't I'm like he
thought I was punking him you know what
I mean he's like he's like there's no
way you run like flat you know for six
miles I'm like no no it's just you know
I didn't start that or what you know I
ran a half marathon like last year like
just you know like okay it's not and I'm
not saying like everybody should do this
it's just like but you can run you know
it's it's easier it can be you know at 2
30. it's very physical if you want to
yeah if you're like I'm I'm about 230
pounds 235 now yeah I do my cardio every
day every morning 30 minutes on the
elliptical on a pretty high intensity
yeah and I just Breeze through it yeah
and you know sometimes you go through
the mountains or something climbing and
you see these other guys that fall off
and they they have to go back yeah okay
yeah you know it's it your legs suffer a
little bit you don't have these freaky
bodybuilder links but at least you have
some stamina to do other stuff you know
because it's the worst thing like you
look great but you can't do any anything
with your body yeah kind of the downfall
of bodybuilding they're all huffing and
puffing and I was gonna say that yeah
like bodybuilders and power lifters we
we like you know you you
and I remember having this mindset of
like oh I'm bulking for football season
like I can't do this you know my
football coach called me out because we
would do this like five mile hill run
every week on like Fridays and he saw me
on the way to it and I was like oh yeah
coach like I'm actually I'm trying to
gain weight right now he's like oh so
you can't run for 45 minutes you know
like once a week I'm like okay okay fair
enough you know because you could like
if it's a calorie thing or whatever you
could just be you know eating a power
bar during the uh Endeavor and probably
you know uh you know being calorically
neutral but
um I yes I that clicked in for me where
I'm like oh this is not having a big or
even a really amazing physique where
you're not necessarily that big but your
cardio suffers like I do I like the idea
of being able to do things and I do
think uh exactly you know yeah when
you're like yeah
you know you don't want to be that guy
because you know buffer guys always get
asked for like handiwork so yeah he
needs to move plus Steve he's strong you
don't want to be that guy that then I
asked to sit on the side while everybody
else is carrying the fridges and the
yeah the couches out of the house you're
sitting on the sidelines to have dude
like a chin splints and my lower back is
pumped you know so but I used to be like
that you know I'd be like 260 pounds
that you can't do anything yeah you know
you look great you're super strong in
the gym you're a [ __ ] animal but then
as soon as you do something else it's
not bodybuilding yeah you kind of
immobile yeah so that's why I kind of
slim down and calm down and that's why I
do you know occasional fasts because I I
set a target for myself okay 230 that's
my maximum weight maybe 235 on a Monday
morning you know after a cheat meal but
that's that's my maximum weight anything
over that I start to get uncomfortable
and I become non-functional besides the
bodybuilding stuff so yeah I do
occasional fast every three months I
don't eat for five and a half days wow
and they do so Saturday morning which is
brutal but I think it's it helps with
longevity you know and yeah again if
you're if you're trying to develop your
physique that might not be a good idea
because you're obviously taking a step
back so everybody's asking me every time
I do a fast I said aren't you afraid to
lose muscle aren't you afraid to go flat
aren't you afraid to lose all your gains
but I've I have all the games that I
want yeah at this point I'm just trying
to maintain what I have and maybe refine
some body parts so you get a little bit
more bubbly here and there but you know
a five day fast I don't even lose
strength at this point yeah just stop
eating I only maybe have a little bit of
vegetables maybe an apple here and there
over these five and a half days I drink
water I take my supplements and and the
next week I go back to the gym and I'm
just as strong you know after a two-day
carb load so yes that's why it really
helps with longevity yeah and that's
really wild because
it's probably more difficult to
determine how much actual muscle was
lost just based on your weight because
obviously like you know the fluid
retention and glycogen and all those
things are going to be huge determining
factors but if you can just jump back on
and you're the same strength
no muscle was lost essentially you could
say right exactly yeah so but when I
when I started doing this maybe four
years ago I saw a video about Dr J some
fun online about the diabetes codes he's
a very prominent guy for fasting how it
can solve diabetes that kind of stuff
now obviously they don't have diabetes
but I saw it as a channel challenge this
is like okay I'm going to take a day by
day stop eating see what happens right I
lasted five and a half days that it's
132 hours
and I really liked it and back then I
did lose strength because I took a week
off from the gym and obviously I didn't
eat I depleted really really hard I lost
12 pounds in a week yeah you know
there's a lot of water intestinal mask
glycogen around like you said and then
the week after I was half as strong but
now after four years of doing this every
quarter sometimes I do it every month
yeah it's it's really no big deal
anymore wow but to be fair I'm also not
as strong as I used to be so there's
there's less of a yeah to fall back so
there's no more 110 pound shoulder
raises that those days are behind me
yeah you know so it's maybe it's maybe
80 or 90. so it's it's less of a drop
than you know maybe previously right
right and you also you know before you
said you would load up on Anna draw the
week before and then stop and then I'm
just kidding but
yeah you time your drugs
lose some fat you know um but uh no
after a while you kind of you know you
start getting close 40 and then it's
like okay then maybe these extreme stuff
I I shouldn't be doing anymore yeah well
I no I I agree with that because I'm
like I do like lifting heavy but it's
like what's the payoff for that you know
in certain ranges of um you know
percentages of your max or whatever I
I've noticed in myself I'm like it's
just you know the risk of anything
happening you know a little pop in your
pack you're like oh yeah I don't need
why am I trying to bench 400 for what
you know
um it's stupid but I just wanted to
comment it's very interesting to hear
you say
um the acclimation aspect and I know
you're not necessarily attributing it to
just acclimation to fasting you're going
like okay you know there were other
factors where I was like going you know
uh my relative intensity was higher when
I was younger to try to achieve these uh
you know strength fees so then maybe
that would account for the drop-off but
in almost everything I do I'm always
reminded I'm like all right it gets
easier even if it's just psychologically
but there's probably some adaptive
mechanism when you do it more I've been
doing a lot of sauna recently and I see
how people yeah you get used to that too
yeah yeah true yeah I think it's just
like like and also like with emotional
distress when you're younger you're 16
years old and something happens it's the
end of the world yes and if something
similar happens now you're like yeah
whatever dude yeah this this is nothing
you know just brush it off you can
continue about your business so I think
it's part of that is adoption right and
then the more you expose yourself to
discomfort of discomfortability or
discomfort yeah
um then it just gets easier over time
you know and then so I've been doing so
many fast now that it's just you know a
switch on and I don't eat or switch off
I push my Hunger aside and I I just ride
it out for a week you know and sometimes
I struggle a little bit on the fourth or
fifth day sometimes times I'm like you
know after the third day I'm like you
know what too much I still need to work
and I can't focus right now
um and sometimes I last six days so
again I just take it day by day and it's
um you know I think as you get older
your goals shift a little bit and you're
just trying to maintain what you have
and and then you can do that on list
drugs and maybe more uh you know
longevity stuff like intermittent
fasting Less Foods less protein yeah
right so that's why it's always a bit
difficult to relate sometimes with the
younger audience because I used to be
you know 20 25 years old do you watch a
40 year old guy say I don't take so much
steroids and I fast a week every month
or every three months full of [ __ ] yeah
yeah he's on a grandma trend for sure
after after a while you're already
developed and if you don't want to
develop anymore it takes very little to
maintain it no yes it takes a while to
start the car but once the car is
rolling it's it doesn't take much gas to
keep it moving yeah yeah no that's
that's true because I'm sort of like I
can maintain a weight of like 250 in the
range of 12 you know not that that's a
prob six three so it's not like I'm huge
but like I remember trying to trying to
get up to 250 to uh when I was playing
college football
um and eating eight times a day and
doing you know I was doing uh DC
training which you know be cool to talk
to you about in a second but I was like
really killing myself at the gym to the
point where like I'd like I had this
like nine to five job during the summer
I was living in this hot City Claremont
which is like in the Inland Empire and I
would sneak out like I'm gonna go uh do
some stuff down here and I'd take a nap
in the middle of the day because I was
just like so you know like super regimen
yeah it's like a full-time job yeah yeah
250. yeah and now it's like in it right
I end up there
um yeah and uh and they're hard to get
to 230 bro right yeah yeah that's what I
was gonna say it's like the real
struggle is you know as I tell people
once I stop eating McDonald's it's over
for these hoes but it's just I don't
know
game over you know so just prepare for
that you know who knows could be today
tomorrow next year I don't I'm not going
to keep you on your toes you know
um but you know I still think it's a
good like we've not that you've been
Reckless but like like I would consider
myself you know somebody who I'm like
I'm willing to experiment and and I know
some people are just never gonna do that
some people would never even do trt or
like I talked to grigo Gallagher
kinobody and I'm like I just know from
his temperament like people accuse him
of being a fake Natty I just think he
has a really great physique but I'm like
talk to the guy he's not interested in
taking steroids you know what I mean he
doesn't have that mindset some guys
don't need it yeah no you don't I still
need it I have I have consultations with
guys that want to start trt and they
send me their blood work in their and
their testosterone is 1600. oh wow
that's crazy I want to start trt I said
dude you don't [ __ ] need me like look
at this as if your your goose egg balls
right now yeah exactly it or they're
down to your knees what you need is like
a sports bra
so you said share it a little bit of
your hips right like that the highest I
got was like 600 700 yeah some guys are
just naturally high and I see them here
in Thailand also they're a little bit
shorter guys and they're they have
genetics out of their ass it's
unbelievable yeah they're shredded the
year round with shredded loads they're
very big muscular and they're round and
the wind Pro shells haven't touched us
there oh wow they do start taking
steroids yeah and it's like Ronnie
Coleman they blow the [ __ ] up yeah it's
you know but that's one in the middle
that's not me unfortunately I was a
skinny fat kid that that after 10 years
of trading I looked
um not even close to a fake Natty so
yeah I I you know swim swimmer for seek
that's the best I was able to accomplish
gotcha and
and and then I took a little bit of
steroids but and then I blew up yeah
because the training was there for 10
years the nutrition was there for 10
years I had a knew a little bit about
supplementation even though now it's way
more developed because it's almost 15
years ago that I started my first cycle
and you know so you get great results
at the age of 26 because you're
regimented right yeah and I think that
is so important as you said you know the
10 years of now I think you're being a
little bit hard on yourself I've seen
her before picks I thought you looked
great you know I don't know your full
story arc or whatever but I was going to
ask you these are Thai guys that you
were referencing with the shredded
glutes or Natty
yeah because I live in Thailand yeah
yeah so sometimes I see some foreigners
come in but most of the foreigners that
have great genetics are either in Dubai
or in the USA because the fitness
industry is bigger there but there are a
couple like tall guys like six four six
three yeah you know from either France
or Italy or or UK or from America that
have good genetics that are natural yeah
and they're killing it on social media
and then they ask me so what do you
think I want to start an anavar Cycles
you haven't done anything you look at
their picture and you can swear that
they're taking something right and you
can even start with their naivetech
you're like oh you're asking me these
questions that indicate that you're not
actually you don't know anything and and
you wouldn't cut if you were con if you
were worried about guarding that secret
you wouldn't probably like ask people
for advice you know no well you know I'm
known as the go-to guy for drug
questions so yeah no I would I always
because I'm like you know we need the
gym you know yeah I'm trying to think of
people who would come Steve would know
about where to buy which pharmacy you uh
yeah I said Monday oh I actually get it
here do you know um her her Instagram
handle is Masha
um she's a Russian girl who lives in
Thailand she knows you I saw oh yeah uh
so yeah of course and I go I'll go oh
hey I'm doing a podcast with Steve
tomorrow and she goes oh I haven't seen
him in a while and I said it's okay I
forgive you
um
yeah so Marsha Marsha's she's lives here
for five years I think or three years
yeah she does some dancing she does some
personal training she has some online
coaching she did a couple competitions
where she looked really really good yeah
she's an impressive patio yeah she's a
great girl she was living in patio for a
while now she's back in Bangkok but
she's usually there in the morning yeah
and I train like night time yeah so I
can avoid all the No No I like the gym
I'm too famous no other Paparazzi yeah
yeah right all the paparazzi so I
changed my schedule because most of my
clientele is in in the western world
yeah right so I wake up at 12. this is a
very single men's lifestyle you wake up
at 12 you do all your work and then you
go out yeah they used to go out to the
club but now I go to the gym around nine
o'clock get my workout in and then I do
all my podcasts or consultations or yeah
you know that's like on Western time so
it works a little bit better this way
and again at nine o'clock in the evening
there's almost nobody there so I can
stomp through the gym and do walking in
between sets to get my steps in yeah
yeah I do I always do that because like
I do my fastest cardio and then I I do
my main workout in the evening I had a
couple meals in and then I walk in
between sets yeah because I'm literally
sitting here the whole day working yeah
you know six days a week yeah so you
know I did the standing disc for a while
but then my knees started hurting a
little bit so I felt that walking in
between sets I get an easy 3000 to 5 000
steps oh wow and you burn a ton of fat
yeah you burn a ton of fat that's no
that's such a great uh you know point
because some of my best physiques have
actually come from doing half an hour
daily workouts but I'm doing circuit
training so that's another just example
of going like you're doing everything
you're getting your cardio and you're
lifting it at the same time a lot of
people will go oh I went to the gym for
two hours and um you know this better
than anyone I'm sure it's like well okay
how many sets how many difficult sets
did you do in those two hours that were
compound movements whatever you know
there's so many factors that you gauge
but people always use this time thing
right like I'm in the gym for two it's
like I don't give a [ __ ] I was in a gym
and lapped on the floor for two hours
once you know
um yeah exactly and Tinder you know yeah
yeah and so but it does like because if
you're gonna end up doing you know
walking cardio after your workout anyway
why not just walk around I think that's
a great idea because I'm always just put
it put it together yeah yeah and and
because after the sets you're kind of
winded and if you walk around the you
know through the gym of course when it's
a very busy gym like I I don't think you
can do this at Gold's Gym or Zoo culture
just too many people yeah I didn't even
lit Muscle Factory here in Bangkok it's
too many people unless it's like after
eight yeah and most people are already
home and I can just do my workout solo
and I walk around yeah
so you you walk around you're winded in
between sets anyway so why not walk it
off literally yeah get a little bit of
steps and burn a little bit of extra
calories but get some oxygen and blood
flow going yeah and I found it works
very very well even for leg day but for
leg day I'm usually hauling plates you
know from one side of the gym to the
other oh nice you know it is with
commercial gyms right yeah yeah it's not
by choice it's a commercial gym so I've
got all the plates one week are here and
then I know you're like oh okay so
there's no 25s anywhere in this whole
you know and people leaving like stuff
on the like I'm I'll I remember going to
the gym the other day and looking around
I'm like there are six like Hammer
Strength or barbell like stations like
that I'm just looking in the immunity
every single one of them somebody left
the weights on you know exactly every
single one yeah that's uh you know it's
amazing but it's horrible dude that's a
good uh that's a good life
and you mentioned um yeah so sorry I was
going to say uh you know an Abrupt a
left turn not really but I you know I I
know we could talk about a million
things one of the things that I like
about your channel like I do think
people should go if you're interested in
you know just educating yourself on out
of box but you also touch on a lot of
different other things and I always feel
like you know people ask me what's your
podcast about and I say it's Fitness
adjacent or Fitness is the starting off
point for so many other things when I
talk to men who become role models
usually Fitness you know it's something
you do to develop self-esteem and then
you know with that self-esteem what do
you do you go out and try to meet women
so I know I've seen at least one video
you know
um talking about this and like again you
don't read like some pickup artist but
I'm like I know you have confidence in
interacting with women and maybe you
could share some of that like your
little you know a journey or a process
um you know because I know I've I can't
think of the exact stories you've told
off the top of my head but I know I've
seen videos of you talking about like
going out and kind of just like meeting
women in general or making this part of
your routine you know in addition to
your other lifestyle stuff like moving
to Thailand and yeah yeah
it's just mostly getting over social
anxiety because I think like I come from
Holland originally and in this small
City close to Amsterdam that I grew up
with people are not very social so I
developed a little bit of social anxiety
where when you go out you don't really
know how to interact with people
properly so I suffer from that from the
well until 22 23 years old and then I
went to Thailand and everybody's super
social here yeah you're talking with
random strangers and you're acting like
best friends so I I came to Bangkok
super easy going with people and then
you go to Phuket which is a tourist town
and of course you're in the tourist
industry so it's it's a little bit more
friendly because they need your business
obviously so but it was so easy to get
in touch with people and within two
weeks my social anxiety was gone yeah
really really it was so easy to get in
touch with people it's very easy to get
in touch with women and then you know
and with guys and it just you know easy
conversation going yeah then I took them
back home and it was very easy to
communicate with people as well but
after while it kind of dies down again
because everybody there also suffers
from social anxiety and is not very
playful and interacting with each other
so that's what what are the reasons why
I decided to move here because I like to
talk with people and socialize and and
[ __ ] and have fun and yeah you know
meet new people all the time
and so I decided to move here and here
it's just a matter of exposure therapy
so I tell a lot of people that are in
the Western World they have a little bit
of a difficulty you know getting in
touch with women or or just socializing
in general come to Thailand
it'll be gone in a month yeah because
you have no choice right you have no
choice you throw yourself in the deep
end yeah and you start socializing yeah
with people and you can even start off
with the ladyboys right like as your
intermediate staff they're going to be
they're gonna be approaching you they
won't leave you alone yeah
dude it's funny when you come to
Thailand the first time you don't know
who's the girl and who's a [ __ ] yeah
because they're that good so yeah
they're very good at that especially now
with the with the surgeries and
everything you wouldn't know yeah so
luckily if you if you go to certain
nightclubs they're not there because
generally it's kind of frowned upon they
don't want the light it was there and if
you go to other nightclubs there's a
very high likelihood that there's
ladyboys so
depending on how fast you want to get
over your social anxiety and start
interacting with people you might want
to go to the yeah right because your
brain doesn't know the difference right
yeah so so as long as it's in the dark
and you you whatever happens in Thailand
stays in Thailand it never happened just
don't tell your mates
and if you you know if you go to a
regular club with nice girls again they
will approach you and and after a while
you start to you know become a little
bit better at that game and then you get
that confidence to approach as well so
and if you already have that confidence
where it's easy to talk with women you
know and and here it's a [ __ ]
Paradise yeah no that's there's so many
beautiful women here that are very easy
going and it's
it and they're different from Western
women you know so like Western women
they get like the beautiful ones they
get chatted up all the time right but
after a while they get bored and they're
like oh you need at least you know a
million and a BMW and the the laundry
list of requirements yeah before you can
talk with them it's kind of high and
here that doesn't seem to be the case
yet but it is getting more competitive
right no it's interesting like because
yes these things it's like you can you
can have a beautiful woman who uh you
know has a more normal temperament or
who is in sort of entitled or doesn't
have these super high expectations based
on how men are treating her if she's
been normalized and similar happens it
hasn't been treated like a special other
right
um so I'm sure you know I'm sure it
exists to some degree everywhere but yes
in the people do seemingly complain
about this phenomenon in the Western
World you know that that um and I don't
know like I hate to jump in and be like
women these days or this or that you
know like I think the odd observations
probably have truth to them and that I I
over the years I do see value in you
know I mean even just having a woman
who's like oh you you know your brain
hasn't been hacked by this idea that you
know you deserve everything just for
being hot
um you know so and I do think again if
you're super hot and you take care of
yourself okay you know yeah same as a
guy that takes care of his physique you
know you should be you have a little bit
higher standard than everybody correct
yeah I get it yeah I get it you did you
you came to that point yeah just gotta
remember that you know when I was in
Harlem trying to you know date hot girls
yeah
um and Holly's known for having hot
girls right like there's some of the
dude from my from my perspective maybe
you can correct me because sometimes
they're like you know like like that's
what it's that's what it's known for but
again you you can tell me you're you
know compare the two usually at the
usually at the dance festivals you know
Holland is the biggest dance festivals
in the world yeah that was always a lot
of fun you know there was always a good
place to get in touch with people but to
be fair everybody's using recreational
drugs there so yeah the the barrier has
been lifted and everybody's each other's
friends yeah so that was always a good
experience and I would go to all the
festivals and have a good time but then
it's in between those festivals and
winter time where you're kind of bored
yeah and and to be fair you know when I
was in Holland I was not a successful
and developed as a person right as I am
now yeah Thailand has changed me I'm way
more easy going and you know I think for
men to if you really want to go get into
the dating game it's it's probably best
to develop yourself first right right be
be your own man like if you live at home
you're not making so much money living
home with your parents you're not making
so much money which at one point we all
did right you're making a little bit of
money you live you know in your bedroom
and are you going to get girls over
right yeah there's this aspect of
self-improvement that that kind of has
to go like with bodybuilding with
getting girls you know the the the uh
Link in the middle there is like make
yourself better if you want more success
in this field where success is rewarded
exactly
and and I think if if at one point if
you're successful and you're good at
what you're doing then it shouldn't be
difficult to achieve anything with girls
or anything with business and but it's
always a roadblock to get to that point
and that's why I tell people I said make
a plan for yourself for one or two years
I made a video about the blueprint for
Financial Freedom yeah how to you know
do the do to do the job where you could
just make the much money as much money
as you can if you even if you don't have
education make as much money as you can
with whatever job you can find pocket it
all
make sure you have a Year's worth of
savings right in the meantime that
you're working you can do all the
research to start a business or how to
start a social media account or figure
out where you want to live and figure
out how you can save as much taxes as
possible right because there's much
better places to pay taxes than your
home country probably so you've figured
it all out the first year you work you
save your money the second year you'll
make your dreams happen yeah and now
people are showing up to Thailand who've
done that yeah and I meet them which is
crazy oh oh you said I put that right
yeah you you put this video out like
yeah if I if I were if I were to get a
do-over this is how I would do it right
because it took me not not two years it
took me like seven years before yeah I
made it happen but so I put all that
knowledge of of The Seven Year Journey
from Holland to here where you're
self-employed and you make enough money
to survive and have a good time yeah put
that all into a two-year plan
and then now people I think I released
it a year ago or one and a half years
ago now people are starting to show up
in Thailand I watched this video a year
ago one and a half years ago I saved all
my money and now I'm here making my
dreams happen and it yeah I've seen 10
of those guys already wow but it's crazy
to me so not even just one you've seen
it yeah
no no it's multiple guys yeah yeah yeah
so you're that's something I never
realized about YouTube how much of a
positive influence you can actually have
on people you know really changing their
lives yes coming here with with you know
twenty five thousand dollars or fifty
thousand dollars worth of savings that's
a big step and some of these guys
already liquidated all their stuff they
don't have a card they don't have an
apartment they sell their Furniture
they're really here to make it happen
yeah and and just start starting new
yeah and that's really cool to see that
is very good that's really cool that is
very cool to see and I think that's kind
of like one of you know we'll we'll
you know hopefully do multiple podcasts
in this series of you and I talking
there's a million things I want I was
like gonna plan it all out but I'm like
I'm just gonna let you know the chips
fall where they may because you know
there's so many topics but I one thing
that I was gonna say is that you know
the reason I'm drawn to your channel and
your personality is because of things
like that where you go yes I'm having
this positive impact on the world and
that's actually a big consideration
you're not somebody like you do sell
stuff but you're not on there using
click bait thumbnails and spreading
misinformation for the sake of profit
you know you're leading with experts
trying to do it yeah no I really like
that's right you make good thumbnails
but you're not going like whoa like
crazy thing is gonna make you gain 50
pounds in four weeks you know at least I
don't I don't title it that that it's
clicky and you don't get what you expect
yeah I always feel like I've never
clicked on a video of yours and like not
had the thing that I was expecting
happen you know
um and there was one there was one video
though I said there was one video I said
the safest performance announcing drugs
that you can take risk-free oh and then
I made a list and I just put three dots
something dude there's no I know I
remember that one and that's but that's
a funny that's but that's still like an
ethical clickbait thing it's like
teachings you know sneaking this like
moral lesson into like hey dummy you
know you're not going to take anything
that's performance enhancing that comes
with zero risk duh everything is Rich
you know but I I do I think you know
you're on a sort of short list of people
again with uh the guys so you do it's
the bio Bros podcast right that you do
with uh Leo and uh and and also somebody
who I correspond with and I just I'm so
drawn in by people who really take the
time to hone their expertise and you do
offer paid services but you're you're
giving so much away for free and so I
just hope like you know you you are
growing I think
um at a steady Pace it would seem but I
think you're doing it the right way and
I I I'm just glad that you and the guys
like you you Steve uh it's uh Derek Leo
and uh and yourself uh you know amongst
others like Mr Barnett that we talked
about earlier
yeah we have we have Paul Paul Burnett
to chase irons and there's think a big
bodybuilding media we've got five
podcasts per week yeah and it's all
solid information and yeah you know like
I think for my my audience it's very
Niche content yeah so I'd never expected
it to grow fast yeah and some sometimes
you make videos that actually tank yeah
and then the later they pick up a view
so you check it like six months later
and there are twenty thousand views yeah
you know the first week they only got a
thousand right [ __ ] what happened what
did I say what did I do wrong you know
yeah later on they pick up but I think
like I wanted this channel to kind of
have like a catalog of information yes
that people can benefit from now but
also 10 years from now yes yeah and so
it's great ideally it's it's just
basically something that I wish I had
when I started my my ped journey and
maybe life in general because I put some
life advice in there as well yeah and um
you know it's just a steady steady
growth I mean I'm at 60 1 000
subscribers now so that's quite big
already and it's yeah more than enough
for you know surviving you know I do
almost two hours of consultations every
day yeah yeah and no and I think that
that's a lot the people who do you know
subscribe to because and that is a very
impressive number for YouTube and uh and
I think you know many people don't have
the appreciation for like you know get
500 followers on YouTube just you know
posting information content
um and and but the people who do come to
your channel they're loyal because I
think they they respect the expertise
but um you know unfortunately I have to
run to go shoot fighter and the kid now
I really just want to thank you for
taking the time uh to talk with me yeah
and I really do not only hope we'll do
more zoom but you're coming to La as we
discussed before and so I would say look
for round two you said in December
yeah middle of December I'll be there
probably seventh eighth or 9th December
yeah we'll hook up I'll bring my uh my
best suit yeah I'll look good next to
you and your best your your best
Stringer
yeah best Stringer right okay and then
uh and then we'll do this in awesome for
sure thank you so much Steve yeah have a
great sleep I guess I guess you're going
or are you training first
no no no I'm going to bed in an hour
yeah okay all right we'll talk soon
Steve all right have a great day thank
you everybody all right ciao